uh this is from the new york post it
says a woman who claims she was booted
from a plane because her stomach was
showing says that she was actually
discriminated against for being a fat
tattooed mixed-raced woman
fairbanks alaska resident raylynn howard
33 alleges she was harassed by alaska
airlines staffers on friday in turn she
did what people do these days to state
her case she took to tick tock to post a
now viral video
originally shared via her fat trophy
wife account on friday
the clip has
um speaking of a contradiction in terms
the clip has since racked up 1.3 million
views and more than 180 000 likes as a
monday morning in the footage howard can
be seen getting escorted off of a flight
by police officers who proceeded to
question her about the incident
uh she said quote throughout my life as
a fat person i've had to deal with fat
phobia especially growing up in the
midwest but not to this degree
um
she said i felt like i was being
discriminated against for being a fat
tattooed mixed race woman which in turn
left me full of emotions like anger
disappointment helplessness humiliation
and confusion
okay now she recorded her uh
conversation with i think it was the tsa
officer which apparently that
that's something they'll let you do well
they let her do it anyway she pulled out
her phone she's sitting in the room
just talking to the tsa officer
pulls out her phone starts recording
and um here's how that conversation went
so so happened on the on the
i was harassed about my outfit okay
i put my shirt back on
so you did have it off yeah
have this on sports bra
they asked me to put my shirt on
put the shirt back on and then they
approached me again
saying that i can't wear this
my stomach is showing and it's
inappropriate
and i said i'm covered up i'm fine
and she just kept going and i said
if you're going to kick me off like then
kick me off i've done what you've asked
me to do
i want you to leave me alone
that was the third time they approached
me okay about my outfit
about wearing this outfit yeah
okay so she was she was wearing her her
bra on the plane just her bra
she she boarded the plane in her
underwear
and then was shocked when they uh asked
her to get off of the plane
get off the plane why i'm just sitting
here in my underwear
this is this is a fat phobia she says
can we go back i mean
we've got all these rules on the plane
already um
and you have to wear the damn mask
and everything else
here's one rule that i would actually be
in favor of let's let us let's let us
take the stupid masks off
but um
a rule that i'd be in favor of if if the
airlines chose to impose it would be a a
much stricter i mean they have dress
codes but how many a much stricter one
if i was in fa if i was running an
airline
i think i'd go back you you think about
like the 1960s and 70s
they used to dress they used to wear
their sunday's best to get on an
airplane
which kind of makes sense because it's
it's an event
right you're you're flying through the
sky this is this is a you know it should
be a great event in your life no matter
how often you do it
that you're able to
travel you know 35 000 feet in the sky
and we we've become so jaded and
you know cynical about it we're so used
to it that we don't stop to think of how
incredible it is
so it actually makes sense
and the other reason it makes sense to
to dress more formally on a
plane is because you're
you're locked in this metal tube with
other people
and so you should make even more of an
effort to be presentable
yeah it's probably true no one else on
the plane wants to look at you in your
underwear you can you can call that fat
phobia all you want call what you want
but they shouldn't have to be locked in
a plane with you for three and a half
hours in this small condensed area so
let's go back to that
for doing all the rules anyway how about
you have to dress for
certainly no no sports bras
um but also
no pajamas
okay no flip-flops
i shouldn't have to sit here on the
plane with you an inch from me and i got
to stare at your hairy feet the entire
time that's not okay either
no flip-flops
you know make formal formal attires what
should be required on planes
in my opinion
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated